[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce premier set 8
sport de la saison vous connaissez le
programme le magazine est consacrée
comme vous le savez à l'actualité
sportive dans le département c'est parti
pour le sommer football ont joué ce
week-end le troisième tour de la coupe
de france manie l'amour recevait le
blanc-mesnil un club placé huit
divisions au dessus des manies croit la
magie de cette compétition at elle
opérer le résumé est à suivre dans
quelques instants
golf un compte à rebours a été installé
au centre sportif les pyramides de
voisins-le-bretonneux il indique les
jours qui nous séparent de la ryder cup
la plus grande compétition golfique au
monde qui se tiendra en septembre 2018 à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bridges and
chinoise a réussi à devenir championne
du monde de la discipline cet été à lyon
nous avons rencontré mathilde thuiller
dans sa maison à villiers saint frédéric
son portrait à dans ce magazine
et puis coup de projecteur sur les
principaux résultats du week-end dans le
département
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par une
large page coupe de france de football
ce week-end ont joué le troisième tour
de la compétition dans les yvelines
manier les mots club de 4e division de
district recevait leblanc mini le club
de nationale 3 malgré une belle
résistance lémanique oies se sont
inclinés à 6 buts à 2 retour sur la
rencontre les images sont signés à
nicolas dans des clubs de fin pour magny
les hameaux en coupe de france le petit
poucet blinois qui évolue en noir ce
dimanche s'est incliné 6 à 2 au
troisième tour de la compétition contre
le blanc mesnil
l'équipe qui évolue huit divisions au
dessus des manies croire tactiquement
ils étaient là au dessus au niveau du
quadrillage du terrain et touba c'est
très compliqué de les contenir
il y avait des appels de partout est
vraiment un niveau d'écart ça se ressent
on savait à l'avancé que ce serait
difficile après la logique banc
elle fait que à chaque fois ils ont été
réalistes devant le but et
notre côté on a fait ce qu'on a pu on a
pris du plaisir surtout lémanique ont
même fait mieux que de prendre du
plaisir sur le terrain malgré
l'élimination les joueurs ont réussi à
faire douter leurs adversaires pendant
la seconde période en inscrivant deux
buts sur coups de pied arrêtés et en
enchaînant plusieurs séquences de
conservation du ballon
dans notre ve schéma de jeu dans notre
construction de jeu dans la conservation
du ballon il pensait qu'on allait
balancer devant alors qu'on a et j'ai
essayé de construire et dans notre phase
défensive transmise à pas moins de gêne
aussi c'est une très très loin de
certaines marques et surtout que aulas
il voulait pas encaissé de but et ils en
ont encaissé dès aujourd'hui nous ça
nous fait du bien au moral pour le reste
de la saison et voilà après cette
parenthèse coupe de france lémanique où
elles devront se mettre rapidement dans
le quotidien du championnat
ils affronteront dès ce dimanche 17
septembre le club de l'ueh civils lors
de la première journée 2 des 4 objectif
monter à la fin de la saison
on continue à parler de la coupe de
france dans ce set 8 sport nous allons
prendre maintenant la direction de
montigny le bretonneux le club qui
évolue en première division de district
recevait à domicile le mais ce dimanche
l'équipe 2 régionale une quatre
divisions au dessus des inimités il n'y
a pas eu de miracle monti le bretonneux
s'incline 4 buts à 1 après avoir concédé
deux buts dans le premier quart d'heure
de jeu mais pour l'entraîneur de
l'équipe jérémy fans et l'essentiel est
ailleurs
qui était au micro de nicolas landry
qu'on va retenir c'est qu'on est capable
sur épisodiquement d'élever notre jeu
sur face à des équipes qui sont censés
être plus forte que nous et nous se
servir de ça pendant l'année dans notre
championnat pour se dire voilà quand on
a joué des équipes meilleures on était
capable un moment donné de résister ou
de vous pouvoir même contre attaquer au
corps on s'appuie là-dessus pour pour
scorer de la saison on regarde
maintenant les autres résultats dans les
environs de saint quentin en yvelines
trappe qui évolue en r4 si lourdement
incliné contre colombes 92 une équipe de
n 3 sur le score de 4 à 1 à domicile
versailles de son côté est allé
s'imposer sur le terrain de
noisy-le-grand 1-0 villetaneuse est venu
à bout de voisins-le-bretonneux dans un
match spectaculaire qui s'est terminée
sur le score de 3 à 2 enfin plaisir qui
évolue en d2 de district à réaliser
l'exploit sur son terrain contre la
colombienne
l'équipe de r 3 score final 2 à 1 du
football
encore et toujours dans ce statut de
sport mais cette fois ci
chez les filles l'équipe féminine des
moins deux saisons de guyancourt a une
belle surprise en fin de saison dernière
elles ont pu rencontrer les joueuses de
l'équipe de france pendant une session
d'entraînement à clairefontaine juste
avant leur départ pour l'euro pour nous
parler de ses souvenirs nous avons avec
nous au plateau le président de la ftq
en cours guigal anti la coach de
l'équipe fanny du para et la capitaine
yasmine habchi bonsoir bonsoir
alors avant de regarder un extrait de
cette rencontre guy gallant tic comment
l'équipe de guyancourt at elle fait pour
rencontrer les joueuses de l'équipe de
france or c'est la chance je crois utile
en cuir noir la chance une longue liste
donc on a été choisi par tirage au sort
et là surprise c'est de les voir arriver
chez nous tourner un petit documentaire
sur le foot amateur et ça s'arrêtait là
pour nous et à notre grande surprise on
a été invité à clairefontaine
c'était pas prévu du tout à la bave pas
pas du tout à la base et puis donc bon
je crois que toutes les filles étaient
contentes
la coach aussi et et à clairefontaine la
plus grande surprise c'est de voir
arriver des joueuses de l'équipe de
france elles ont participé à un
entraînement et vous expliqueront ça et
ensuite elle est la grande surprise
c'est que à la suite de cette rencontre
toutes les joueuses de l'équipe de
france les ont invités à venir voir un
match pendant leur ou en hollande
plein de souvenirs donc dit à l'anti en
garde tout de suite un extrait de cette
rencontre
[Applaudissements]
son génie
ça va ça va les filles ça se passe bien
bonjour
j'ai beaucoup aimé qu'on a c'est arrivé
parce qu'on n'était pas au courant c'est
cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un rêve de les rencontrer et se réaliser
voilà donc apparemment vous allez nous
battre au défi si vous ne battez vous
prenez notre poste en équipe de france
[Musique]
on fait ça on a la pression parce qu'on
a envie de bien les faire vraiment de
belles images et yasmine vous avez
encore beaucoup d'émotion je les ai vus
dans vos yeux pendant de longs
reportages déjà vraiment beaucoup cost
est énorme énorme une une sensation
incroyable de les voir en face de nous
une personne et c'est trop bien vous
imaginez les rencontrer un jour
franchement non franchement non
peut-être un match oui peut-être mais
franchement là c'était une surprise je
ne m'y attendais pas du tout du tout
mais qu'est ce que ça change justement
de les voir en vrai plutôt qu'à la télé
ou dans un stade
mais c'est deux fois mieux déjà elles
prennent le temps de te parler de
rigoler avec toi de juste de jouer ta
passion avec les personnes que tu
regarde tout le temps la télé d'être fan
d'elle franchement c'est c'est
incroyable fanny qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'elles auront appris pendant ces
cessions je pense de l'an viii de la
motivation pour continuer et
ça leur a montré aussi je pense ce que
c'est de jouer en pro que joey hand
dictum et de pouvoir continuer après
dans le futur à la faute finalement
c'est un bon complément peut-être avec
votre rôle à vous de coach oui ça fait
déjà super plaisir parce que nous s'y
attendait pas personnellement à vivre ça
et
et même pour elle quand on voit qu'elles
sont toutes contentes que nos joueuses
sont en train de pleurer quand elle
voyait et les joueuses de l'équipe de
france ça fait vraiment plaisir
yacine qu'est ce qu'elle vous ont appris
techniquement peut-être est-ce que vous
aura pris des gestes techniques et
notamment je crois les tirs sur la barre
transversale bas juste un joint avec
elle justement bas on prend exemple sur
elle donc oui à nous après nous ferait
millions il garantit réaction ah c'était
je crois que pour elle et pour nous et
pour le club
bien sûr c'était d'abord très agréable
d'avoir été choisi et puis je crois que
pour les filles
pour le club c'est un moment inoubliable
je crois que vous en rappellerez
longtemps nous aussi j'espère que ça va
se poursuivre sur d'autres actions de ce
style là et pourquoi pas parce que on
n'a pas rompu les contacts au contraire
yasmine vous clairefontaine qu'est ce
que vous en avez pensé parce qu'ils
aient eu l'équipe de france féminine
c'est déjà énorme on peut le dire mais
il ya également à clairefontaine à côté
le centre de l'équipe de france mais
juste en mettant son pied sur le synthé
d'où elle ajouté c'est une sensation
c'est une émotion c'est waou on se dit
bah là on est en train de jouer où elle
joue elle de base de franchement c'est
fait c'est fait m fille de mots pour
expliquer sa famille quand allez vous
les avez récupéré à l'entraînement il
était comment différentes peut-être je
pense qu'elle était impatiente
alors passons
de continuer déjà d'aller aux pays bas
et puis même de les avoir vus je pense
que déjà ça les avait un peu a
bouleversé et
après je pense que ça leur a fait
plaisir et c'est ce qui compte vous les
avez senti peut-être plus motivés à
l'idée d'être joueuse professionnelle
peut être un jour basso tooway quelques
joueuses qui ont pris vraiment
quelque chose dans la tête quand elles
les ont vus et c'est ce qui compte c'est
leur ressenti c'est que moi allons
suivre ce à prix garantis juste le
préciser que la série sur le web existe
toujours et il ya toujours ces éclairs
mon club et mettre un club amateur à
l'honneur du jeu encore et donc il ya à
peu près une dizaine de vidéos qui trace
un peu tout le parcours qu'elles ont
font alors que les retrouve énormément
faudrait juin juillet donc on peut le
retrouver sur le sur le net
alors il ya également aussi une grande
politique finalement de sport féminin
dans le fbi en cours est ce qu'on peut
nous en nous en parler alors on s'y
intéresse depuis quelques années alors
on est un petit club départemental
on espère atteindre le niveau régional
oublier pour quelques unes de nos
équipes masculines mais le foot féminin
c'est vraiment une pratique qui va se
diversifier on y croit beaucoup
il ventait beaucoup sur le football
féminin est en pause et on fait tout
pour que les féministes s'installe au
côté des garçons au même niveau avec le
même nombre d'équipés tu sais
alors on va peut chercher le niveau
national bien entendu mais au moins
avoir une participation aux votants égal
aux garçons pour les filles
en tout cas au sein de notre club mais
on est très très contents très très
heureux de les avoir avec nous il ya
d'autres opérations de ce type qui sont
prévues dans les prochains mois oui on
fait d'une certaine surprise
vouliez pas généraux des spectateurs
divulguer tout de suite mais il ya des
opérations qu'on va mener opération
portes ouvertes
on va aller vers les écoles on va aller
on va développer j'en suis sûr le foot
féminin
et puis je suis très heureux d'avoir
beaucoup d'éducatrice tels que fanni se
maintenant tu n'est plus tout seul
elles sont quatre cinq six sept filles
je crois qu'ils vont passer des diplômes
et qui vont se former pour encadrer nos
superbes féminine voilà merci à tous les
trois les passer sur ce plateau pour
commenter cette belle rencontre on
continuera évidemment à suivre l'équipe
de guyancourt à tous les étages cette
saison que ce soit chez les filles comme
chez les garçons du ballon rond on passe
au ballon ovale les championnats n'ont
pas encore repris dans les yvelines les
équipes sont actuellement en pleine à
préparation la semaine dernière nous
sommes allés du côté du stade de
porchefontaine à versailles pour
observer l'équipe seniors le club a
travaillé à tout l'été sur son effectif
pour réaliser une grande saison le
montage est signée à pascal josèphe
renforcement musculaire mais les
contacts finies les vacances rugby-club
de versailles
l'équipe senior est en pleine
préparation à l'aube d'une nouvelle
saison du championnat ile de france
honneur un travail intensif en vue de
réaliser les grandes ambitions du club
l'objectif est clair cette année il faut
qu'on monte en fait le droit et
globalement avec les joueurs le groupe
quand en train de mettre en place
on a tous les ingrédients pour pouvoir y
arriver alors après évidemment il ya
tout ce qui peut arriver à intervenir
surtout courant dans la poule est aussi
du club au succès qui se renforçait
parmi les clubs qui se sont renforcées
on retrouve notamment l'équipe de
sarcelles la structure investi plusieurs
milliers d'euros pour créer une équipe
capable de monter les seniors au niveau
fédéral et pour le coach alain jamin il
faudra aussi rester concentré face aux
autres équipes de cette poule 2 je pense
qu'il ya pas mieux qui peut encore jouer
le trouble-fête comme la saison dernière
à bagneux équipe toujours difficile à
jouer
après il ya d'autres équipes vitry on
avait perdu chez eux je pense que cette
année c'est pareil il avait un nouveau
staff l'an dernier cette année ils ont
une vie une année en commun aussi fort
je pense que sur le papier a priori
travers la sarcelle versailles mais je
pense qu'on a d'autres derrière qui sont
comme ça va être cool à mon avis encore
assez homogène comme la saison dernière
pour réussir à tenir son rang et à
lutter pour les premières places le rcv
a décidé de recruter et d'intégrer des
jeunes afin d'étoffer son groupe
aujourd'hui près de 80 joueurs sont à la
disposition du coach
on avait juste un effectif juste voilà
pendant une partie de la saison on a été
obligé de faire jouer les bélascain en
réserve
pratiquement il a 3 3 joueurs par poste
complètement différentes qui va se jouer
premier match de la saison pour verser
le dimanche 1er octobre sur le terrain
de gif sur yvette est saison dernière en
honneur versée avait débuté par trois
défaites consécutives
un mot de baseball à présent les coûts
garde sont actuellement en demi-finale
de play-off de première division après
avoir esata terrassé le puck de paris au
tour précédent les imans teint sont en
ballottage défavorable face à rouen ils
ont perdu les deux premiers matchs 6 à 2
et 10 à 3 pour nous parler du parcours
de montier bretonneux cette saison et de
ce match qu'il vient de se disputer nous
recevons sur ce plateau
annie couton la présidente des cougars
de monty bretonneux et rodolphe le meur
le coach de l'équipe senior bonsoir
alors comment analysez vous cette
rencontre contre ans qui vient de se
passer
on s'attendait à avoir une grosse
opposition parce que c'est quand même le
champion en titre est multiple champion
de france c'est vrai que le tirage on
aurait préféré tomber contre sénart
qu'on avait déjà battu en saison où on
ne l'avait pas battu sur quatre matches
donc la tâche était rude
et en effet on a réussi dans le premier
match à les accrocher un peu et puis le
deuxième match a été a été un peu plus
clair ils ont une grosse attaque ils ont
des gros lanceur donc c'est vrai que on
a encore du progrès on a encore une
marche à gravir pour arriver à ce niveau
rouen reste quand même une grosse
machine à battre aujourd'hui à niveau
tour il n'y a pas de honte à perdre
contre aurons c'est la meilleure équipe
on peut le dire de france actuellement
tout à fait dans toute façon nous
d'arriver en demi-finale c'était que du
bonus pour un promu donc non nous ne
sommes pas honteux et en plus nous
n'avons pas fait un match qu'ils étaient
des matches qui étaient défavorables
donc nous en sortant la tête haute pour
le moment et comment vous analysé cette
saison vous êtes en demi finale de d1 en
étant promu est ce que la saison est
réussie trouver dans tout à fait toute
façon c'était lorsque nous étions venus
au début de saison avec rodolphe notre
objectif au départ était de nous
maintenir
et puis après quelques matches nous
avons eu comme objectif d'être appelé
dans les play-offs est donc là nous
avons largement atteint notre objectif
puisque nous avons passé le premier tour
des play-offs et nous sommes en
demi-finale donc pour nous c'est une
saison réussie vous attendez vraiment
être en playoffs en début de saison
j'aime bien me fixe et du gros objectif
c'est vrai que comme annie l'a dit on y
vous l'avait annoncé sur atv 78 c'est
mon jeu
vraiment qu'on aille en play-offs égal
et comme j'avais dit chatouiller un peu
les grosses les grosses machines comme
voir mon petit nid sénart on a réussi
sénart notamment les a battu plusieurs
fois pendant la saison régulière
montpellier hérault on n'a pas réussi
mais voilà de leur île à la saison il
est vraiment vraiment réussi enfin tout
cas moi je suis vraiment fier de ce que
de ce cas de ce qu'a produit mais mes
joueurs et on pouvait on n'espérait pas
une personne très peu de gens nous
attendent et puis c'est vrai que les
promus du premières années puis on avait
aussi la mauvaise expérience qu'il ya
six ans on avait fait 28 défaites voilà
on voulait on avait un coeur aussi de de
montrer que montigny peser y avait sa
place en d1 et pouvait faire des bons
résultats
vous avez réussi à mettre en place un
style de jeu dans cette équipe
oui il ya plusieurs il ya plusieurs
choses et une grosse préparation quand
même cet hiver on a fait en sorte de
vraiment se préparer à la hauteur d'une
division 1 il ya le recrutement aussi
qui a vraiment été impeccable c'est vrai
que recrutement quand on fait appel à
des étrangers on sait jamais sur qui on
va tomber ça peut être si c'est un peu
la roulette russe
soit vous avez des joueurs vraiment à la
hauteur de lance de leur engagement soit
vous tombez sur des déploiements plus ou
moins bien et là vraiment on a on a
réussi à faire un recrutement de deux
points alors notamment du côté étranger
mais aussi avec des français qu'on a
récupéré d'autres clubs qui sont
descendus de division est
et puis en fait j'ai aussi on a réussi à
créer c'est vraiment cette cette osmose
que c'est important on a beau avoir
quinzaine de talent dans une équipe si
vous créez pas cet esprit groupe est ce
c'est cette envie de gagner tous
ensemble ça fonctionne pas donc c'est
vrai que tout tout tout tout ça a fait a
fait qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve en
plein de division annie couton cette
année le club était en demi finale
est-ce que l'année prochaine mais qui
peut encore s'améliorer et atteindre la
finale voire remporter le titre
ben pourquoi pas toutes façons tout
dépendra peut-être du rock hautement
tout va dépendre de recrutement
d'intersaison je peux comme l'a dit
rodolphe il faut encore qu'on arrive à
créer une osmose
mais je pense que rodolphe et puis alex
sont suffisamment judicieux pour faire
des bons choix
donc c'est la balle est dans leur camp
il faut il faut il faut pas se le cacher
c'est un côté financier aussi qui est
important il va falloir qu'on aille
chercher
sûrement un peu plus d'argent puisque
qui dit étrange et ben il faut les faire
venir en france
il faut les loger c'est vrai que dans la
région le prix du prix du logement c'est
pas donné
donc voilà il ya quand même un côté
financier qui va pas falloir ni exigé il
va falloir sûrement aller chercher un
peu de un peu de financement pour
pouvoir rassurer et faire venir aussi
des étrangers de valeur comme le font
rentrer ce que roy en voilà ils ont ils
ont ils ont des gros gros joueurs mais
bon ils ont ils ont aussi une partie
financière importante qui leur permet de
faire venir des joueurs importants alors
nous allons parler maintenant d'une
autre thématique qui concerne les
cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux
le stade jean maréchal l'enceinte où
vous jouez vos matchs et en plein
lifting
la ville a déboursé près de six cent
quarante deux mille euros pour rénover
les terrains de la structure pendant
l'intersaison le synthétique daté du
début des années 2000 on écoute le
responsable du service paysage et
environnement à montigny-le-bretonneux
et on revient avec vous juste après en
fait on va voir quand même un moquette
synthétique de qualité conformes lusage
baseball
chose qui n'était pas forcément évident
sur l'ancienne moquette
bon après on a aussi les normes qui
évolue régulièrement donc là on sera
vraiment
jour des dernières normes alors pour
l'instant le synthétique n'a pas encore
été livrée c'est une déception vraiment
amis de ne pas avoir pu jouer cette demi
finale à domicile
oui c'est jean marc création oui pour
nous et aussi pour les joueurs et les
spectateurs
est ce que c'est vrai que ce serait
sûrement aidé les joueurs de pouvoir
avoir l'un spectateurs che avec eux mais
bon maintenant il vaut mieux attendre
pour pouvoir enfin avoir ce que l'on
attend dé vous attendiez à ce qu'ils les
retards vous l'aviez anticipées oui mais
on s'attendait à ce qu'il y ait du
retard
on vous avait dit fin août normalement
on nous avait dit fin août
nous on s'était mis comme objectif on
avait dit ça sera sûrement mi septembre
parce que bon des travaux en période
estivale
ça prend toujours un petit peu de retard
dû à différentes à différents amours
d'érable donc maintenant bon c'est vrai
qu'on va sûrement finir la saison sans
avoir le terrain mais c'est pas grave
puisque de toute façon après on va avoir
un outil de qualité
donc on préfère attendre et puis pour
afin à voir ce que l'on attendait depuis
de nombreuses années rodolphe ça sera un
vrai plus vraiment ce nouveau terrain
synthétique
oui bien sûr c'est facile c'est
formidable d'avoir de ce2 et l intérêt
quel terrain en france et c'est quand
même assez exceptionnel il ya très peu
de clubs qui peuvent se targuer d'avoir
un terrain synthétique de 2
de cette qualité et puis en plus nous
dans un stade enfin on aura le seul
stade français de baseball tous les
autres c'est des terrains c'est vrai
comme on avait quand même des
infrastructures vraiment qu'ils
s'adaptent de plus en plus et on
l'attend avec impatience est vrai que là
on aurait aimé jouer nos play-offs mais
c'est pas grave on a déjà eu
l'opportunité et la joie de ce sera pour
l'année prochaine là c'est pas un
problème on va si c'est vraiment
incroyable d'avoir ce type de terrain
ici là dessus là vraiment on remercie
beaucoup la municipalité enfin vraiment
la ville pour de nous permettre de
pouvoir jouer sur des conditions
vraiment idéal merci à tous les deux
dépassé sur ce plateau à bientôt et on
vous souhaite de remporter à vos trois
matches qu'on trouvera ce week-end pour
vous qualifier pour la finale du
championnat de première division hameau
de golf à présent la ryder cup la coupe
du monde de la discipline se tiendra du
28 au 30 septembre 2018 sur le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines au
rendez-vous opposera les meilleurs
golfeurs américains aux meilleurs
golfeurs européens pour sensibiliser le
public à cette manifestation la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux a décidé
d'inaugurer ce samedi matin pensons
forum des associations un compte à
rebours géant au centre sportif les
pyramides
on écoute la maire de la commune
alexandra rosetti au micro de mélanie
poquet parce que la ryder cup va se
passer presque un voisin je dis toujours
c'est presque parce que c'est aux portes
de voisins et que j'aimerai que lévis
sinois je dirais profitent de cet
événement soit conscience de l'homme de
l'envergure de l'événement
de ce que ça peut apporter à notre
territoire donc c'est vrai qu'on a
souhaité
on allait les associés en ce jour de
forums et puis que ce soit dans le
gymnase qui qui voit passer parce que
deux cent mille personnes par an la
billetterie de la ryder cup 2018 ouvrir
à la fin du mois de septembre pour vous
inscrire il faut créer un compte avant
ce jeudi sur le site officiel de la
compétition
à noter également dans vos agendas
mercredi à lima au pérou le comité
international olympique donnera
officiellement à paris l'attribution des
jo pour 2024 pour cette grande journée
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines va organiser
des animations plus de 800 enfants
participeront à des stands sur le thème
du sport
il y aura également de nombreux sportifs
français comme les golfeur thomas levet
alexandra bonetti l'escrimeuse astrid
guyart et l'athlète ice et à diawara du
côté des paralympiques et yoann qui nous
sort en séance dédicace la journée se
terminera par des démonstrations à
gratuite de l'équipe de france de
cyclisme sur piste et parent direct pour
suivre la lance depuis lima 20 heures
pour plus d'informations rendez vous sur
le site de saint quentin en yvelines
coup de projecteur à présent sur un
sport qui n'est pas encore olympiques
mais qui pourrait le devenir dans les
prochaines années
le bridge ces disciplines pratiquées par
plus de 100 millions de personnes à
travers le monde se joue à quatre avec
un jeu de 52 cartes dans les yvelines
nous avons une prodige ou devrais-je
dire un as dans ce sport mathilde
thuiller de villiers saint frédéric qui
est devenue championne du monde pendant
l'été son portrait un montage de à
xavier jaglin c'est désormais l'une des
meilleures joueuses international de
bridge mathilde et willy 21 ans
étudiante en troisième année de médecine
a raflé cet été la médaille d'or de la
discipline à lyon dans la catégorie
girl's par paire sa passion pour ce
sport s'est construite entre ses murs à
villiers saint frédéric avec ses parents
depuis ses 8 ans mon mari joe masseur
joue la maman de marie jo ma maman joue
la famille aujourd'hui mathilde de vie
comme une vraie sportive la joueuse doit
faire attention à son alimentation et à
sa récupération avant les compétitions
pour s'entraîner lajaunie blinoise
participent à des tournois mensuels et à
des parties en ligne sur internet donc
la main partenaires n est pas disponible
du coup je vais jouer contre des robots
mais c'est un petit peu le même principe
enfin ici le vert une fois par semaine
un soir on en 1h30 2h à l'entraînement
régulier indispensable pour avoir toutes
les cartes en main pour réussir des
compétitions c'est un sport puisqu'il
faut tenir toute une après
d'ivoire parfois toute une après midi et
toute une matinée pendant plus d'une
semaine et c'est un entraînement sur
toute l'année et en plus il faut avoir
une bonne condition physique
parce que si on est si on est trop
fatigué par exemple on pourra pas jouer
on ne pourra pas tenir toute une semaine
de bridge prochain objectif pour
mathilde de revenir avec des médailles
d'or des championnats d'europe en
croatie des championnats du monde de
shanghai de compétition organisée l'été
prochain c'est une véritable tradition
comme à chaque rentrée en septembre les
parents et les enfants passent par les
forums des associations pour s'inscrire
aux différentes activités sportives
proposées dans les villes ce week-end
avait lieu de nombreux forums comme on
peut le voir en ce moment sur ces images
tournées à coignières et à voisins le
bretonneux
mais si vous avez raté ces rendez-vous
pas de panique les club enregistre les
inscriptions jusqu'à la fin du mois de
septembre
n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner
directement auprès à des structures un
dernier rendez vous à noter dans vos
agendas avant de se quitter en handball
c'est la reprise pour les féminines de
montigny le bretonneux dans le
championnat de nationale 2 lésiné
monteyne se déplace ce samedi sur le
terrain du paris saint-germain objectif
cette saison pour les saint-quentinoises
la montée c'est la fin de six sept huit
sports merci d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine d'ici là passez une excellente
semaine sportive très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]